the european union and the united states
are friends and allies
our citizens share the deepest of links
the election of the president of the
united states of america
is therefore a moment of significance
also on this side of the atlantic
we have all been following the electoral
process closely
and it is clear now that the 46th
president-elect is joe biden
i congratulate him and vice
president-elect kamala harris
on their victory together
the united states of america and the
european union
have built an unprecedented partnership
it is rooted in common history
and shared values of democracy freedom
rule of law the respect for human rights
social justice and an open economy
our partnership has underpinned the
rules-based international order for
decades
and remains a pillar of stability
security
and prosperity on both sides of the
atlantic
as the world continues to change
and new challenges and opportunities
appear
our renewed global partnership will be
critical
the european union stands ready to
intensify cooperation with the new
administration and with the new us
congress together we will address
pressing global challenges the corona
pandemic
and its economic consequences
climate change and the loss of
biodiversity
the necessary rule book for the digital
economy and society
global security and the reform
of the rules-based multilateral system
i look forward to driving this global
agenda
together with the next president of the
united states joe biden